because when i asked myself why i kept
looking for new things why i was bored
why i kept changing um i think i was
looking for a meaningful and a deeper
purpose
and i didn't know about it but once i
had that moment that
commitment really to my co-founders that
we're doing this for the long term i
found the purpose that's just deeper
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright excel an immediate
partnership with c-tech
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders i'm honored to have such a good
friend of mine on the show today tomer
london the co-founder and cpo of gusto
tomer is the co-founder and chief
product officer of gusto a software
company helping hundreds of thousands of
businesses start build and grow their
teams he's optimistic easily excitable
chronically impatient and a loving
father of three and a really good friend
of mine welcome tomil
welcome to 20 minute leaders how are you
i'm great thank you so much for hosting
me here and we're in israel yeah but
usually we see each other in san
francisco you're the chief product
officer and co-founder of gusto yeah
honestly one of the most amazing
companies that i know of not just
because you're in an amazing space and
you're helping small businesses in in an
amazing amazing way
but the culture that you're helping
build and the mentality that you're
bringing with you wherever you go as a
person mainly i'm inspired by it thank
you and so i really want to thank you
first all for the friendship and the
mentorship and for agreeing to do this
it's going to be a lot of fun yeah 10
years
10 years at gusto yeah you were doing
your phd at stanford after eating your
masters
started three people
10 years later do you believe you're
there for 10 years
yeah well i i was i was just i was just
thinking about this so um so it started
three people around almost 10 years ago
now now 1500 gusties in uh
remote so everywhere basically but our
main office is san francisco denver new
york as you said we're helping uh
over a hundred thousand small businesses
in the us hundred thousand yeah and
actually much more we just these are
this is the the official the official
the official number but numbers much
higher but over a hundred thousand small
businesses to start build and grow their
teams these are people just like my dad
who has a small clothing store in haifa
and um you know small businesses are
just a huge part of my life and huge
part of so many people's lives and
helping them is is helping people who
are the underdogs and social mobility
and and people who make the community
you know what what it is and much much
more wonderful and colorful so
really really feel privileged to be
working on this but it's your question
about you know 10 years i never thought
i'll do anything for 10 years um i don't
think i've done anything before gusto
that's been more than three years three
years the military
in israel so
and i really struggled and even within
the military i changed jobs multiple
times and i always was the type of
person who would change and look for the
next challenge and get bored really
quickly and want something else and
and i think there's kind of two sides to
it the first one is
actually the job my job as a co-founder
and product person in the company has
changed basically every year or two
organically being the head of product in
a three people or a 10 people company is
very different than being the head of
product of a thousand people companies
the job itself itself really really
changes and what you do really changes
um but i'll tell you something else
which is uh more in the deeper level um
because when i asked myself why i kept
looking for new things why i was bored
why i kept changing
i think i was looking for a meaningful
and a deeper purpose
and i didn't know about it but once i
had that moment that
commitment really to my co-founders that
we're doing this for the long term i
found a purpose that's just deeper it's
a purpose that's within
um
obviously the customers that we serve
it's a purpose that's to my co-founders
and we're here we committed to each
other that we're doing this for the long
term and we're here to do this and
and kind of being there and
for one another is very very meaningful
um it's a purpose around gusties and
helping them achieve their career goals
and their dreams
and i think all of these this kind of
brings me to this point around
motivation that comes from purpose and
that's what i really really believe in i
feel um
i feel like it's really easy in today's
world where you are so
free and open and you can do anything
you want you know you go into the world
and you can be this or you could be that
you can do this you can do that you can
choose to solve this problem or that
problem which is the mindset of many
many folks who are starting companies um
having some sort of a commitment having
some sort of commitments that you either
choose or you fall into or you're born
with
coming into your family commitment to
your community communicate to whatever
that is your country whatever that is is
a wonderful pulling force to give you
purpose um and
that's what keeps me going for 10 years
now and i think we're going to keep keep
me going for a long time
where do you find that purpose though in
the day-to-day is it is it in the
day-to-day isn't it the higher level
idea of what gusto is doing to the to
the small businesses
is it in the friendship that you're
building with your co-founders what does
it really come down to
i think um for me that when i when i ask
myself that question of
what are my commitments
right what is i would say what is my
purpose then the first question after my
purpose is let's look at my life let's
look at the commitments that i have to
people
and
ask myself how can i do better
so
let's start with like fam on my family
side like how can i be a better husband
how can i be a better father how can i
be a better family member how can i be a
better friend and when i look at this
and how can i be a better co-founder and
so forth and when i look at these
commitments um
when i'm in my lowest slopes when i'm in
moments that are
that i feel not motivated when i'm in
moments where i feel like that i i kind
of lost my way and i'm not sure why why
i'm doing what i'm doing anymore and
what's driving me forward and that these
are moments that happen to everyone and
definitely happened to me along the way
um
i do that search
of
wait a minute what's my commitment and
can i do better and that just gives me
tons of purpose so i i really believe in
that point that um
purpose is in your commitment
one of the things that i asked you
before
that really were meaningful to me and
i'm going to take with me for a long
time
was this question of being a good person
right and this question of what does it
mean to be a leader and at the end
you know 500 episodes and i still
haven't really figured out what what it
means to be a good leader because it
changes but
one of the things that you that you
started mentioning was this idea of
you know what is it when do you know
that you're a good leader and that
ambition tell me a little bit about your
perspective on you know leadership in
the day-to-day and this aspiration well
first i feel like i feel under qualified
to
give an answer to like you know what's a
good person or what's a good leader but
he's very qualified but but again i'll
tell you what
what i've seen in other people and what
i try to emulate myself um i think this
journey of constant improvement
if you if you when i see people whether
i interview them for a junior position
or whether they interview them for like
you know
like running a huge huge department in
gusto um
whether it's an entrepreneur that's
raising their first
seed round ever or whether it's someone
who's like you know their third company
they're raising a
you know a late stage round
what i'm looking for and what i've seen
um is the best indicator for long-term
performance
is this idea of constant improvement so
looking at like what mistakes have i
done
and then let's make sure i don't do them
again and i learn from that and move
forward and what would have gone well
and how to make sure to do more of that
and i think that's true both on business
but also in your personal life um taking
thinking about you know your
relationships thinking about people that
you hurt because you've hurt people
that's just a part of unfortunately a
part of life think about the people that
you hurt thinking what you can learn
from that and how can you do better next
time um obviously going back to them and
amending and and talking about it and
being honest and humble like hey i make
mistakes
um here was my intent
and here's what ended up happening and
i'm here to improve and i'm here to
change and uh we're all here to do this
and i think when you go through a life
where when you think of yourself less of
a static thing and more like a living
breathing changing well you are living
breathing but changing um constantly
learning improving and growing from your
mistakes um
it's just like a much lighter load in
life too because it's okay you let give
yourself the opportunity to make
mistakes that's really important but
it's pretty challenging in a world where
we're almost being taught to run forward
and chase and forget about the past and
and you know chase after something 4-2
yeah just because a lot of what you're
talking about is stopping reflecting a
little bit backwards at what we did and
who we are who we may have heard and how
to and how to think through resolving
that that that's that it takes a lot of
maturity
to do that you know what what what do
you find works for you
as you're able to because you're leading
you're you're helping lead a company of
1500 people
responsible for you know the day-to-day
of over of more than a hundred thousand
small businesses how do you have the
time to stop and reflect am i being a
good husband am i being a good father a
good leader yeah yeah um everyone has 24
hours every day and it's all a matter of
your priorities so i think for us it's a
part like for gaza and augusta world
it's a part of our culture so you know
doing these retros asking yourself
what's going well what what what what
didn't go well that's one and just you
make time for this this is like a part
of our weekly
operating rhythm whether you're within a
pod of engineers or whether you're
within a larger leadership team asking
stopping and saying what went well what
didn't let's talk about it let's learn
from it and move forward and there's no
it's not about blaming you for learning
um
but also in terms of relationships so me
and my josh and me josh and eddie are my
co-founders um you know we still today
10 years in we have every week we spend
time together and we talk about things
and we try to be we're i think we're
kind of very self-reflect reflection
type of people and we talk about these
things talk about what went well what
didn't we talk about hard things we give
each other marital advice so give each
other advice about like you know raising
kids and um and and i think in a
relationship that's long term and and
commit and committed
you also have the opportunity to give
people advice like tell them the truth
in the face and that's really important
to be on the receiver end of that
because you know i just had a
conversation with josh two weeks ago he
gave me some really really hard truths
to my face about something actually
about about my family and
that was incredibly valuable because
there's just a very few people who know
you very well for 10 years and tell you
some things and help you then resolve
things as a result um
and you know relationships take time to
build and that trust takes time to build
um so um
that's a huge part of what makes anybody
10 years in yeah
an amazing company that is still growing
and still making a big difference
and what it sounds for me and your
perspective get only getting started and
really building it for the long term
what have you learned not just about
building a great business but building a
great culture you know you're a part of
you know i walk into the gusto offices
besides the fact that i put my shoes
aside and i put the amazing green and
blue socks
what have you learned about building
really a family of 1500 people yeah yeah
okay because a couple things i think so
when we we take our shoes off in the
office um and you know people get
slippers so they can walk around like
you know without their feet being too
cold the reason that that we do that is
when we started the company we started
in our house uh josh and i were
roommates and in our house we take our
shoes off but we grew up in a family
like that so we just continued with that
and
once we moved to to our first office it
just felt very natural to keep going and
uh
still today that's the situation now
we're going to go back you know to the
office from uh covet and everything so
we'll see how that evolves um which is i
think an important point around like
culture should evolve it shouldn't be
static but um uh but that's been pretty
cool for 10 years now and we have so
many socks we basically create every six
months or so there's a new line of socks
gusto socks
i know
you got you got to come visit and then
you get i missed two collections you
probably missed quite a bit
and um um and people have these kind of
wall of socks and yeah like there's some
cool cool stuff around but my daughter
thought we were a sock company
actually
um
thank you i can totally see that yeah
they got the socks everything's
disgusting um but yeah it's your
question what did you learn there's a
lot there's a lot obviously but i would
say
um
being intentional
around your values and around your
principles and what makes you you what's
authentic to you and how you want to
build a company is really important and
if you don't go and define it and do the
work
um
it's just going to happen to you so
couch culture either you define it and
it happens or according to what your
overall direction is or or it just
happens to you and then you need to kind
of fight it um and i think in gastro we
were always
kind of
two steps ahead in terms of what we
should be doing according to the book in
terms of like did you define your values
well we did it a little bit earlier than
most companies like when we were like
four or five people as opposed to like
when we were 30 people
um
do you have like a career path with like
leveling for every single department and
all that stuff we did it when we were
around 20 people as opposed to many
people wait until they're 50 80 and so
forth and that's kind of being a little
bit early is on one side feels as a
startup person it feels like
why are we wasting our time it's hr
stuff and and instead of let's go build
and serve our customers but i think that
the other approach looking at this is
people are the most important thing that
makes your company they build the
product they serve the customers they
come up with the ideas they make
everything and if you want to make sure
you bring in the right people you want
to make sure you bring you you help them
grow in a way that aligns with your
culture to the long term and so this is
a very very worthwhile
um
set of things to do so i highly
encourage
um to be um to kind of take this this
really um
you know thoughtful approach to a little
bit ahead of the curve spending the time
having a tough conversation ahead of
time to really talk about values so
stuff commercial because you josh and
eddie you came from different
backgrounds different countries
different cultures yeah it can't be that
the three of you had the exact same
vision for how the company is going to
look like throughout the 10 years
those three co-founders where
you know how do you how do you handle
through that because this is really you
know building values for a family how do
you how do you deal with those types of
conflicts yeah let me just say something
about family so i think i learned
throughout my time in gusto and i think
every founder learns this is that
companies are not families
you don't manage people out in families
you you stick up with stick with your
families perhaps no matter what
um and companies are more like teams in
my opinion and it means that
you know we are all here together for a
mission the most important thing is the
customer and doing doing a great job for
them and we as gus these are important
obviously but we are only here to serve
someone else um so sometimes there's
just not the right alignment like
whether it's not about someone who's a
bad person it's this is not the right
time in their career it's not the right
fit for their skirt skill set where they
want to go to where gusto is going and
then you need to part ways and that's
okay that's totally fine um so i would i
would highly encourage uh founders to
not use the family language as early as
possible because when you transition
from we're family to we're a team
a lot of early employees may not like
that um but it's an important thing to
important companies to have but about
your point around like you know founders
and alignment and values and all that
stuff actually that we were quite
aligned and i think value is something
that you do come um from home with and
from your life experience values around
what do you value over something else so
an example of a value is just what i
said like what's more important the
customer or the employee and some
companies will say one some companies
will say another and that's okay and
there's different ways of building
company and i think josh eddie and i
connected on like actually quite a like
we're here to serve the customer it's
more important for the cut for for us to
have um an impact on our customers for
our small businesses and their employees
in america um
than than our teams
and that's the hard thing to say but
values are they need to be hard if it's
all like
do good
and if if you talk about a value and
there's no trade-off implied then it's
not really a value it's just like a
truism like do good of course everyone
wants to do good
yeah
sure thomas thank you so much for
sharing this time with me i really
appreciate that i have a few more
questions about you though i want to i
want you to take me back to your
childhood okay
middle school kaifa okay what really
fascinates you as a kid you're walking
down the streets what what you know what
drives you in your day today
yeah i did okay the short short answer
the long answer i think the the short
answer right so okay so the short answer
for this is um
i loved books i loved standing in front
of big shelves of books about any random
topic and just feel the enormity of the
stuff that i i could be learning
and one side it was intimidating but on
the other side was truly inspiring to
just see like there's so much i don't
know yet and i wanna and i have i have
my life ahead of me to go and learn that
then i love that that's just like so now
in my as a parent
i try to have books everywhere in our
house because i know it's it was so
meaningful to me well a specific genre
that was the most fascinating to you i i
like actually like non-fiction i like
like just learning about things like
really having psychology wow biology
books like science books and just like
anything i just love the idea of
learning new things today something that
inspires you either an event a person
some mission
kids
kids inspire me today i feel like you
know as you know i've three young
children five and she raised five kobe
is uh three in la vie is one
seeing how they develop and uh and and
learn and grow it's just so inspiring
because you know the growth rate and and
their the ability of them to pick up new
skills and um and just seeing how their
thought process changes and just in
front of your eyes is is inspiring and
it's one it's just wonderful
and what are three words you would use
to describe yourself three words to
describe myself um
i'd say i am um
optimist
say i'm very impatient
and
let's see that's the last one just
family member
this is amazing
continue making a huge impact with
augusto thank you for inspiring me
for two years now
really appreciate it thank you for
everything and stay safe and stealthy
[Music]
you